that was the issue David Cameron warned
his party to stop banging on about when
he was elected as leader a decade ago
but the debates about Europe has only
gathered steam after failing to reach a
deal last week in Brussels the Prime
Minister is gearing up for yet more
negotiations with EU leaders in February
but it's reported almost half of all
Conservative MPs have already joined the
euro skeptic group conservatives for
Britain while I'm joined now by the
organization's co-chair Steve Baker and
a very good morning to you mr. Baker I
want to ask you first of all for a
direct response the former Chancellor I
can't lock on this program about an hour
ago
said well you're a skeptic so euphemism
for right-wing nationalists I was very
disappointed to hear him say that
because just a few moments before he
said I think we should treat one another
with respect well I agree we should
treat one another with respect and I
think he has noble reasons for thinking
we should be a near you all costs but I
consider myself a liberal
internationalist of the old kind I want
to live in a democracy and as the Prime
Minister said do you use too bossy and
too undemocratic so I hear what he says
I think he's wrong and I think we need
to we need to play the issues not the
people if we're going to stick together
okay so to the Prime Minister in
Brussels last week I mean you kind of
think I guess don't you that he got what
he was going to get wasn't asking for
very much in your book and still didn't
even get that he was asking for what
Lord Lawson said was inconsequential and
indeed he has gotten consequential
commitments I mean look at the benefits
position we've been told that we might
be allowed to go in a position of
supplication after the damage has been
done to withdraw benefits which the obr
has told us would make not much
difference to migration this is not what
colleagues are looking for they'd like
to better treat people equally whether
they're from outside the EU or within it
and that means having British migration
policy made in Britain for whoever is
outside the UK so even if he got the
benefits cap and it's a big business but
even if he got that you saying that's
not enough well he won't get the
benefits cap on it isn't it but even if
he did even if he did it wouldn't be
enough no we think British migration
policy should be made in Britain and
people are very clear about it when
discrimination is mentioned in this
context you have to remember that
migration policy is being made on the
basis of EU citizenship which came in
under master
on which I don't think the British
public have ever really warmed to we
think of ourselves as British citizens
now this isn't about how nice people are
we all love Europe I think most
conservatives have a very warm heart for
you for Europe this is the issue about
having consent for the levels of
migration that we have and our public
services being able to absorb the people
who come so what you endorser the words
in terms of those negotiations and we
know they're going to go on that the
Prime Minister hoping to wrap them up in
February Liam Fox also a member of your
grouping talking about the Prime
Minister parading about Europe with a
political begging bowl it's strong
language but I'm afraid it is true I
mean look at other issues like the
tampon tax we have to go and go in a
position of supplication or with a
political begging bowl asking to be
allowed to do things which really a
sovereign Parliament should be able to
just take care of so I'm afraid Liam Fox
it is right but this is what the
position that the EU will put any
British Prime Minister in it's not about
David Cameron it's that if we're in the
European Union any British Prime
Minister will find themselves in a
position where they can't even ask
Parliament to pass the laws which they
know our country needs and that's why I
think we should leave but people would
say and some people are saying - you
know would you at least let the
negotiations continue to their
conclusion before you make up your mind
this issue was raised again floated
again perhaps seemed to gone away for a
bit of the emergency brake on EU
migration of course that would be
operated from from Brussels they decide
when and how it operated but
nevertheless that perhaps for a period
of time would would stop large numbers
of the EU Nationals coming to the UK
well people have several times said
we've been a bit premature and I would
have loved to auth waited till the end
but let's remember that when we were
first elected we thought there was an
outside possibility the referendum might
have been held by now so we have to come
out of the blocks quickly we had to make
sure we started building a campaign
which we've successfully done but
creating the impression we'd have a
quick referendum had the consequence
that those of us with strong views had
to come out of the blocks quickly so so
that's why we we've moved fast it became
evident very early that the Prime
Minister wasn't going to ask to give the
Parliament of Ito over EU law for
example that happened on the 7th of June
when the Foreign Secretary said having a
veto is tantamount to exit
well people continue to flow
with it Boris Johnson wrote an article
saying Parliament should have a veto but
this is the truth
conservatives are in a great battle
between gut instinct their heart which
tells them they love Europe and they're
pragmatic head which tries to resolve
the mess in the end I think most
conservatives will wish to leave what I
wanted to ask you and that the in the
introduction I gave there about your
assessment of the strength of support
that your group has within the party
let's start with Boris Johnson there
he's quoted this morning as saying he
thinks the Prime Minister should be more
robust with his European partners well I
think it's fair to say we would like the
Prime Minister to be more robust because
we're very clear that most of us want to
end the supremacy of EU law and make
British migration policy in London and
so on but we aren't where we are the
Prime Minister's in a position where
he's being pragmatic and wishes to keep
us in a reformed EU well you can see
which way he's leaning he'd like to keep
us in I think Sir John Major let the cat
out of the bag this morning on the Mars
show it seems clear to me that what the
establishment would like is for the
public to vote to remain in and then
they'll finesse all the details later
this is never going to work as even John
Major said this morning with
subsidiarity it didn't work before and
his argument was well this time we'll
get it right look at history are you
going to trust politicians promises on
this issue or are you going to vote to
leave and force politicians to come back
with the right deal that does end these
problems which even those in favor of
staying in typically recognize as this
from a politician but what is your
assessment within the Conservative Party
of your level your views level of
support I think that over half the
Conservative Party is strongly leaning
to leave there are a hundred and fifty
colleagues signed up to the
Conservatives for Britain mailing-list
there's another 15 and we'll have over
half the party you know I think some of
them will just be keeping an eye on
things some will be just keeping an eye
and there's a small number as I've said
I think there's at least three who are
simply keeping an eye but that's fine
but what I've seen over the last few
weeks is that colleagues are
substantially hardening up they're
seeing the way we're conducting
ourselves which is to play the issues
not not the personal in prime minister
and their hardening up in saying this
deal justice and how deeply does your
support penetrate into the cabinet I'm
not going to speculate on any particular
member of the cabinet but people's views
must have had conversations with them
well people's views are well known there
are several years sceptics in the
cabinet
said in the past for example that they
would vote to leave if the question was
tomorrow and I think we're now
approaching a point that the question
tomorrow will be on substantially the
same basis as it would have been then so
if those members of the cabinet are not
given freedom to speak their minds what
there's going to be something of a
pantomime for several months so I would
like the Prime Minister to give them
freedom to campaign as soon as possible
but let's just be explicit about that so
you're saying to the Prime Minister when
you come back with whatever agreement
you've been able to get you say to your
cabinet you're free now free to vote
we're to campaign and vote wherever you
like I think our party in our country
and the quality of debate would be best
served by full freedom for the cabinet
on this issue so it will happen if
that's not given I think it's inevitable
that some members of the cabinet will
feel they have to resign if they're
browbeaten into supporting a deal which
honestly is this flimsy I think there
are problems ahead but I hope there'll
be no need for resignations because I
hope the Prime Minister will give them
freedom to speak up on an issue which
many of them have held strong views on
for many years and would you have high
hopes of capturing one of them to
actually lead your campaign you could do
with a really high profile figure it's
not a question of capturing and you know
I've had many colleagues conversations
with colleagues I feel sure that there
will be a place for any colleague who
wishes to have a a strong public profile
on this issue so what you think you
could get some of that Boris Johnson
Teresa may in Duncan Smith someone like
that
I need your campaign to be the public
but I'm not going to speculate on any
particular member of the government but
if you look at the vice president's of
conservatives for Britain and indeed
Lord Lawson our president it's quite
clear that there are a good number of
previous members of the cabinet who have
joined us already in a public role and
I'm sure that if anyone else felt they
needed to leave the cabinet we would
accommodate them very easily and I'm
sure you could thank you very much
indeed mr. Vyse well very good to talk
to you Steve Baker